and you can't even escape free back in
the house you're in can you because the
from series 1 the the wall of penises
that's in your house I see that my house
yes they're all they're all here keeping
me company are they close at hand could
we have a look yeah they're actually
they're actually stored here while
they're waiting to go into the office
we're because meant to be going maybe
it's my office you know we're never
locked down it's over and I'm hoping it
will eventually become a hat stand or
something adorable like that but this is
this is who welcomes people when they
come to the door like a couple of months
ago you know my sister and I live here
and when we put it there first real like
it would be temporary and then you know
when you just put something down in your
house then you don't think about it
raiding then it becomes invisible to you
and you forget that you have like 12
massive penises at your front door and
this delivery guy came he wants to go
and open the door and I just completely
forgot he couldn't had to like bring
something in and he was like knocking
against the Coxes he was coming in he
was like and I was like oh and I
suddenly saw them again for the first
time in ages like oh god I'm I'm so
sorry and he just let me dead in the eye
and he went it's art never apologize for
art
[Music]